ما نعرفه وما لا نعرفه على حد سواء مهم جدًا ،
لذا دعني أبدأ بالجزء السهل
من هذا الاختبار ، ما نعرفه عن
ثلاثة أشياء نعرفها على وجه اليقين عن
المدعين العامين أولاً وقبل كل شيء
السبب المحتمل الثابت لارتكاب جريمة فيدرالية محددة
لقد أثبتوا
أنه من المحتمل أنهم سيجدون
دليلًا في الموقع في mar-a-
lago ونعلم أن ذلك تمت الموافقة عليه من قبل
قاضٍ فيدرالي حسنًا لدينا
أن بقية هذا لم تتم الإجابة عليه
أحد أكبر الأسئلة ما هو الدليل  هل
استخدم المدعون العامون لإثبات هذا
السبب المحتمل الآن ، الطريقة التي تفعل بها
ذلك كمدعي عام هي أنه عليك كتابة
ما نسميه إفادة خطية لدعم
أمر تفتيش ، يمكن أن تكون هذه المستندات
عشرات الصفحات ، وهذا هو في الواقع واحد
من مايكل كوهين  القضية التي
يزيد طولها عن 200 صفحة هذا هو حجر رشيد
هذا سيخبرنا بكل ما
نحتاج إلى معرفته من يمتلكه على الرغم من أن
المدعين يمتلكونه لدى القاضي ولكن
هذا ما نسميه تحت الختم مما يعني أنه لا
متاح لنا في العلن دونالد
ترامب ليس لديه هذه الوثيقة في
حوزته ، فلن يحصل عليها إلا إذا
جاء يوم يتم فيه توجيه الاتهام إليه ولكن
لديه شيئًا ما لديه بالضبط
ما نسميه أمر تفتيش هل
لديه  نسخة ، نعم ، هل يمكنه تحريرها؟ نعم ،
ولكن هناك معلومات محدودة إلى حد ما
في هذا المستند ، إنها
صفحة واحدة ، هذه هي عينة
منها ، تخبرك أين سيتم البحث
عنها ، ما الذي يبحثون
عنه؟  أشياء مثل
أجهزة الكمبيوتر الخاصة بأوراق المستندات ، لن تدخل في الخصوصية
عادةً من هو القاضي
ومتى يتعين على مكتب التحقيقات الفيدرالي إجراء
أمر التفتيش ولكن في بعض الأحيان يكون هناك
مرفق بهذا الأمر ويمكن أن يخبرك
هنا بالجرائم التي
يزعم المدعون أنها قد تكون مرتكبة  تم الالتزام به ، لذا فإن دونالد
ترامب لديه تلك الوثيقة ولكنها
لن تعطي فصلاً وشعراً آخر
وثيقة مهمة كان دونالد
ترامب يجيب على سؤال ما الذي
اتخذه مكتب التحقيقات الفيدرالي من mar-a-lago الآن
يسمى هذا  الإرجاع هو في الأساس
فاتورة ، إنه إيصال سيقوله مكتب التحقيقات الفيدرالي
هذا ما أخرجناه من الممتلكات الخاصة بك
ولكن مرة أخرى هناك مستوى من
العمومية مفاده أنهم لن يقوموا بتفصيل
كل قطعة من الورق ، فمن المرجح أن
تقول شيئًا مثل 12  مربعات × عدد
أجهزة الكمبيوتر المحمولة من هذا النوع ، لكن دونالد
ترامب لديه إمكانية الإفراج عن ذلك أيضًا
مرة أخرى إذا كان
غير ضار على الرغم من أن المذكرة نفسها
لماذا لا يفرج عنه هو
احتمال وجود مرفق يحدد
الجرائم التي يمكن أن تكون  أعتقد أن هذا
سيكون أهم شيء إذا كان
هناك هذا المرفق
وغالبًا ما يكون له ارتباط به ،
فإنه سيقول عادةً
إننا نعتقد أن هذه الجرائم التي
أنشأناها قد لا يرغب ترامب في
ذلك ومرة ​​أخرى يمكنه
الإفراج عن ذلك  إذا كان يريد تمامًا
لجميع الدعوات إلى ميريك جارلاند أن
يخرج ويقول شيئًا ما في الوقت الحالي ،
فيمكن أن يفعل ترامب ذلك ، فكل منهما لديه
معلومات ولكن نعم ، يمكن لترامب أن يفرج عن
ذلك بشكل صحيح.  إذا كانت لديك أسئلة أخرى ،
فما هي المستندات التي
كانت لا تزال موجودة في mar-a-lago في
الوقت الذي تم فيه تنفيذ أمر البحث
الآن ، نعلم الآن أنه في وقت سابق من هذا العام ،
تم تسليم 15 صندوقًا من المستندات
من mar-a-lago إلى
البلد  بعد ذلك ، حصلت دوج على
تلك الصناديق الخمسة عشر نفسها من الأرشيفات الوطنية
الآن ، حيث أظهر تقريرنا الجديد
أنه بدأ في الشك
وتعلم أن هناك وثائق أخرى هناك
وبدأوا في الشعور بعدم الثقة
بالطريقة التي تم التعامل
بها معهم ، فدخلوا أمر التفتيش.
وتقريرنا الآن هو أن doj قد استحوذ على حوالي 12
صندوقًا إضافيًا من mar-a-lago ، ما هو
هناك سنكتشفه ، ثم
هناك سؤال حول سبب استخدام Doj بالضبط لأمر
تفتيش بدلاً من وسائل أقل تدخلاً
وهناك أمر مثير للاهتمام حقًا
التاريخ هنا مرة أخرى في يونيو ، هناك
هذه الاجتماعات التي أبلغتنا كايتلين كولينز
وآخرون عنها حيث
ذهب المحققون والتقوا بفريق ترامب
في مار إيه لاجو رأوا أن  تم
توضيح وجود صناديق أخرى من
المستندات في الطابق السفلي ، ثم
عاد المحققون وقالوا إنهم ألقوا
قفلًا يحفظهم لنا ،
فلماذا كان المحققون على ما يرام مع هذا
لماذا كانوا على ما يرام مع تلك الوثائق التي
تبقى في mar-a-  lago لشهور
وشهور حتى 8 أغسطس وحتى يومين
ماضيين عندما نفذوا أمر البحث
، فهذه وسيلة تدخلية
وأعتقد أنه في النهاية سيتعين على doj
تبريرها مرة أخرى وهذا أحد
الأسئلة التي لم تتم الإجابة عليها هنا.
قد يفسر
شيئًا ما ، نعم ، أحد الأشياء التي تم
طرحها هناك من قبل الحلفاء الرابحين هو
حسنًا ، لقد تم رفع السرية عن هذه المعلومات على
أي حال ، نعم ، إذن ، لدى بام
براون تقرير جديد يفيد بأن هذا قد يكون
أحد الدفاعات ، إحدى الجرائم المحتملة
هنا هي إساءة التعامل مع السرية
المستندات التي قد نراها دفاعًا
قام ترامب بإلغاء السرية عنه
الآن ، انظر الآن عليك القيام بذلك بينما أنت
رئيس لا يمكنك القيام بذلك الآن
لعدة أشهر  السؤال هو هل قام
بالفعل برفع السرية عن أنه لا يوجد
نموذج محدد يجب عليك ملؤه لرفع السرية
عن الرئيس لديه سلطة واسعة على
أن السؤال هو ما الذي
يظهره الدليل هل هناك دليل فعلي على
أنه رفع السرية ولكن احترس من
أنه يمكن أن يكون معركة  قادمًا ، أنت
تعرف أن كل شخص يدعو
إلى تقديم معلومات
لميريك جارلاند سوف يفعل ذلك حتى يتمكن من السماح له بذلك ،
وأود أن أسمعه يدعو إلى
مؤتمر صحفي لهذا اليوم ويخبرنا بما
يحدث ولكني لا أعتقد أنه
سيعطي  تاريخه ونظرًا
لمبدأ الادعاء العام المهم حقًا ، فأنت
لا تتحدث عن التحقيقات المعلقة ،
جزء من ذلك هو مشروع قانون إستراتيجي.
لا يُزعم في الواقع أنه
ليس أفضل مثال صحيح ولكن أه
تريد الحفاظ على سرية
التحقيق الذي أجريته ، فأنت لا تريد إخبار
الفريق الآخر بما أنت  القيام بجزء من
ذلك يعد أيضًا مبدأ مهمًا
لحماية حقوق سمعة
أي شخص قد يخضع للتحقيق
بشكل عام ،
لا يريد الشخص الذي يتم التحقيق معه
أن يخرج المدعي العام ويقول نحن
نعتقد أن هذا الشخص ربما يكون قد ارتكب
جريمة  آخر شيء بالقرب
من منتصف المدة هنا هو أنهم يلعبون في
هذا نعم ، لذا فإن منتصف المدة الآن على بعد 90
يومًا بالضبط وهذا مهم لأن
هناك سياسة doj طويلة الأمد
لا تتخذ خطوة استقصائية
مثل أمر البحث الذي قد  أن تكون
حساسًا سياسياً في غضون 90 يومًا
من منتصف المدة ، لذا قاموا بهذا البحث
قبل 92 يومًا ربما صدفة ربما
لأنهم كانوا يحاولون البقاء بعيدًا
عن 90. هل يهم أن دونالد
ترامب لا يركض في منتصف المدة ، لا
هذا لا يعني  هناك طريقة
لتفسير تلك المذكرة من الناحية الفنية ، يا من
يهتم ولكن من الذي يلوح في الأفق خلال هذه
الفترات النصفية أكثر من دونالد ترامب ، عليك أن
تكون واقعيًا إذا كنت تفكر في تفسير
ايلي العسل مفيد جدا كما هو الحال دائما شكرا
لك